today's video is sponsored by under
lucky stars commemorate a special time
in your life or the life of a loved one with
a personalized star map more on them in a bit
in this chat of short lifetime we've covered
endless men who made their mark many became
kings emperors leaders of movements that changed
the course of history but even among this pantheon
it's rare to find men or women who went one step
further who became not just a human figurehead but
the focal point of an entire religion well in this
episode we're going to meet one such man haile
selassie as a mere mortal he reigned over the
nation of ethiopia for 44 transformative years yet
his longest lasting legacy likely has its roots
over 12 000 kilometers away in the jamaica of
the 1930s the rastafari religion coalesced around
the idea that selassie was not just a powerful man
but literally got today an estimated one
million follows of rastafarianism subscribe
to this belief yet who was the historical figure
at the center of it all and how did he become
this religion's messiah born in a mudhut hailey
selassie rose through the ranks of ethiopia's
royal family to become its last emperor as leader
he weathered coup attempts invasion resistance
to his progressive reforms only to at last be
overthrown by his own people powerful tragic and
nuanced this is the life of haile
selassie africa's king of kings
it was july the 23rd 1892 when the boy who would
become highly selassie was born into a life of
both privilege and poverty poverty because his
family like nearly all 26 million of ethiopia's
inhabitants lived in a simple modern wattle
heart within a vast rural country still wedded
to the feudal system and privileged because unlike
most ethiopians selassie had the aristocratic
background to escape this life members of the
powerful amhara tribe selassie's family claimed
they could trace their roots all the way back
to emperor melik the first himself supposedly
the child of king solomon and the queen of
sheba this meant that selassie was also related
to the current emperor menelik ii and you better
believe this conferred certain advantages as a boy
selassie was educated by french missionaries his
father ras mcconan was governor of harap speaking
of selassie now might be a good time to mention
names although he's gone down in history as hailey
selassie the future emperor was actually born
tafari mcconan like his father he was elevated to
the title of ras or duke it's from the fusion of
his title and name ras tafari that rastafarianism
gets its name and while we're on the subject
we should probably also discuss ethiopia if
you paid attention in history class you might be
under the impression that ethiopia in this era
was called absinia which it was but only by
outsiders for this reason we're just going to
refer to it as ethiopia throughout just as we'll
be calling tafari highly selassie even though he
wouldn't take on that name until 1930. got it
well great so let's move on with today's story
when selassie was just a teen his father died
but while this doubtless hurt it also took him
closer than ever to the center of power
taken in by the emperor selassie became
part of addis ababa's political elite eventually
becoming promoted all the way to governor of his
dad's old province it was while working there that
selassie began to truly grasp ethiopia's problems
while the empire was thousands of years old the
nation itself seemed like it was stuck in the
middle ages dominated by a land-owning ability
ethiopia had few roads few large buildings no
organized health care and little in the
way of government infrastructure in essence
it was a feudal society and that was worrying this
was the heyday of colonialism when european powers
were gobbling up so much african real estate
that very very few places hadn't been absorbed
into some empire or another selassie was quick
to define that if ethiopia didn't modernize it
too would become little more than an exotic
outpost to be exploited but what could he
do as a mere governor although he was related
to the emperor selassie wasn't in line for the
throne when menelik ii died in 1913 it was the
good-looking playboy legiasu who replaced him
not the orphan selassie as with his father's death
though selassie would soon manage to turn this
latest set back into an advantage asusi had an
image problem his ancestors had been muslim in a
nation where the elite were all christian so when
he started making moves to de-secularize society
those same elites didn't see a serious attempt to
improve the lot of ethiopia's religious minorities
but rather a diabolical plot to make them
all worship allah and stop drinking their
beloved taige as head of the christian opposition
selassie led the charge in accusing yasu of being
an apostate a traitor and generally just a giant
douchebag when in 1916 iyasu also started making
overtures to world war one central powers it was
the last straw yasuo was overthrown that september
replaced with melanic's daughter zuditu but since
the idea of female rumor was almost as bad to
these guys as an islamic emperor it was decided
zuditu needed a region someone who could give her
reign a shot of testosterone care to guess who
they chose in early 1917 selassie was appointed
zu ditu's crown prince and heir apparent
and so began his unstoppable rise to power
in many ways the pairing of selassie and zoo did
two was an odd one while selassie was aligned with
ethiopia's progressives you do was so conservative
that should make mitch mcconnell look like a
jowly che guevara yet there was something both
empress and crown prince had in common they were
both capable of being staggeringly ruthless it
was often said that selassie crept like a mouse
but had the jaws of a lion and those jaws started
snapping shut even before he became heir apparent
in the battle against yasu's forces selassie was
merciless superior firepower and executions were
deployed to solidify his grip on power it was
brutal but it worked ethiopia failed to spiral
into the predictable chaos combined with the
destruction of yasu's army in summer 1917 a larger
crisis was averted and so the crown prince was
at last free to pursue his long-desired reforms
as the 1920s dawned it was on in ethiopia in the
grip of furious change under selassie's orders
new schools were being opened designed to educate
the children of the elite along european lines a
professional civil service and bureaucracy was
beginning to be brought in taking power out of
the hands of the feudal overlords the first moves
were even being made on the abolition of slavery
although it would be decades before a full-scale
ban was implemented arguably though the most
important changes were in ethiopia's international
relations in 1923 selassie took his country into
the league of nations a kind of precursor to
the u.n with added uselessness to selassie
though the league's collective security seemed to
guarantee ethiopia's safety from colonial powers
as did his burgeoning friendship with those same
powers in 1924 he became ethiopia's first ruler
to make an international trip traveling through
europe's great capitals and schmoozing everybody
while the stated reason for buttering up the
europeans was to encourage investment in private
selassi was more direct saying we need european
progress only because we are surrounded by it
in other words keep the mad colonizers at bay by
letting them invest in ethiopia's booming markets
and in the 1920s those markets were really
booming with coffee selling spectacularly
more money was being freed up to construct roads
and communication lines while a new class of
entrepreneurs was starting to emerge it was in
short a good era for progress but not everybody
was happy in the palace udu and her conservative
allies were stewing at the reforms upending
their nation from their perspective selassie's
improvements were more like unforgivable decadence
the beginning of ethiopia's slide into ignominity
so in 1928 they decided to get rid of him
only to find themselves stepping right into
those lion's jaws the september 1928 coup was
such a failure that zuditu's limited authority
collapsed in the aftermath she was forced to
proclaim selassie negus or king but this title
would only be a stepping stone a year and a half
after the coup in the spring of 1930s uditu was
found dead apparently of complications relating
to diabetes with that selassie's takeover was
complete on november 2nd 1930 the man who had been
born jafari mcconan was crowned ethiopia's 225th
emperor it's at this point that he took the name
haile selassie meaning might of the trinity amid
a lavish coronation ceremony held in addis ababa
salasi's coronation was eye-wateringly expensive
involving all manner of spectacular uniforms and
sumptuous decorations although the european press
including the novelist evelyn war ridiculed it
they were missing the point selassie wanted
to project a vision of ethiopia with as much
pomp and regalia as anything in europe a state
that wasn't a potential colony but an equal to
anywhere where white men ruled eight months after
taking power he set out his new vision for this
ethiopia in writing the 1931 constitution placed
selassie at the center of everything a paternal
ruler who always knew what was best for his people
and could never be opposed from now on the king of
kings would rule as an absolute monarch alright so
we'll get back to today's video in just a second
but first quick word from our brand new video
sponsor under lucky stars under lucky stars make
beautiful personalized star maps that show the
unique alignment of the stars in a place and time
chosen by you this is the original map maker four
stars with a proprietary method of mapping the
stars in the universe verified by astrophysicists
from nasa so you know you gain the real deal how
does it work well all you have to do is enter
the location date and time of a special moment
in your life that you'd like to commemorate and
unlucky stars can show you exactly how the sky
looked at that time with a beautiful map printed
on museum quality thick matte art paper there are
more than 15 designs and six border options to
choose from which means you can create a totally
personalized memento i've got mine right here it's
so big it's so it's a big reflection of my light
but it's not going to fit in the frame right but
uh this is a beautiful one it's actually uh when
my wife and i got married so i got heard that as
a gift for valentine's day you might be thinking
well valentine's day is coming up you haven't got
anything for the loved one in your life this is a
perfect gift it's thoughtful it's just nice
right now you guys can take advantage of an
exclusive 10 discount this valentine's day head to
underluckystars.com forward slash biographics and
use code biographics to get your loved one a gift
they'll never forget and now back to today's video
the first four years of selassie's reign could
only be called benign despotism the emperor
used his sweeping powers to drag ethiopia into
the modern age establishing schools building
hospitals and roads and instituting a police force
the result certainly wasn't a democratic paradise
civic participation was almost non-existent and
the idea of anything as radical as a separation
of powers was little more than a grim joke still
for all selassie might have held the nation in an
iron grip it was at least one wrapped in a velvet
glove his autocratic tendencies softened by real
improvements the next power to take over the
country by contrast would dispense with softness
entirely on the borders of ethiopia in eritrea and
modern-day somalia a fascist power was looking to
expand benito mussolini's dream was to establish
an east african empire one that would include
all of selassie's nation of course as a member
of the league of nations ethiopia was supposedly
covered by its joint security agreement but
mussolini was willing to bet that the league
was even more toothless than it seemed in this
he would be proved depressingly right tensions
started to climb in november 1934 when ethiopian
and italian troops got caught in a series of
skirmishes near the border of italian somaliland
this was followed by a massive build-up on the
italian side as il ducey began preparing for
war but selassie still believed membership of
the league would save him rather than mobilize
he asked the league to adjudicate on the border
dispute he was still waiting for an answer
when the invasion began opening on october
the 2nd 1935 the italo-ethiopian war was
short it was grim and it was humiliating
as mussolini publicly declared he was on a mission
to bring progress to this backwoods nation his
troops unleashed chemical weapons while italian
planes dropped bombs on civilian populations as
one correspondent observed this isn't a war it
isn't even a slaughter it's the torture of tens
of thousands of men women and children with bombs
and poison gas in the face of such dirty tactics
what hope did the ethiopians have on may 2nd 1936
hailey selassie boarded his imperial train and was
taken away into exile three days later addis ababa
fell as ethiopia crumbled some of the italian
commanders suggested that they bomb selassie's
train but mussolini demured with a victory so
complete the fascist leader could afford to be
magnanimous seven months after they first crossed
the border the italians had triumphed one of
the only african states to avoid being colonized
was now absorbed into the colony of italian
east africa yet selassie still clung to the hope
that help might be coming on the 20th of june
150 centimeter tall that's five foot four emperor
stood at a podium before the league of nations
in geneva as fascist observers booed he made a
dignified speech laying out why the league needed
to act how italy had broken international law the
grave consequence of inaction famously he ended
with the prophetic phrase it is us today it will
be you tomorrow at the end of selassie's speech
the delegates applauded then they voted to take
no action while the most powerful nations france
and britain cut separate deals with mussolini and
so the most iconic moment in selassie's life
ended not with diplomatic triumph but with the
penniless emperor exiled to the british city of
bath unable to even afford new books to read but
of course this wasn't the end of haile selassie
just over four years after his league of nations
speech italy invaded the protectorate of british
somaliland bringing world war ii to east africa
sadly for alduce it was the dumbest thing he could
have done in response winston churchill called
selassie out of retirement gave him the codename
mr strong and flew him secretly to khartoum with
a simple goal train up an army of resistance
invade italy's colonies and kick mussolini out
on his pudgy ass it was a plan the king of
kings would carry out with extreme prejudice
when selassie fled the oncoming storm in 1936 he'd
been attacked for abandoning the people the great
coward is how firebrand jamaican activist
marcus garvey referred to him but there was
nothing cowardly about the emperor's return with
ethiopia now recognized as one of the allies the
army of resistance marched on mussolini's empire
in january 1941 from a brutal occupying force the
italians became mere paper soldiers crumpling up
and blowing away in the face of serious opposition
on may 5th exactly five years after addis
ababa befell italian control of ethiopia
collapsed that day haile selassie re-entered
the capital in an alfa romeo as the emperor
stepped out onto the hot streets he was greeted
with a telegram from churchill it is with deep
pleasure that the british nation and empire have
learned of your imperial majesty's welcome home
not that a free ethiopia was immediately
re-established for the rest of 1941 the
country was under british administration there's
some speculation london considered remaining in
control longer but selassie was impatient
to re-establish his authority in january
1942 the british officially recognized and
independent ethiopia not long after selassie
finally did what international supporters
had been hoping he'd do for years
he fully abolished slavery a long-standing form of
punishment slavery had been so entrenched in the
nation that even nominally anti-slavery emperors
like melanic ii had owned hundreds of slaves even
selassie himself is thought to have been a slave
owner nonetheless it was by his decree that the
practice was finally ended part of a second
wave of modernization planned for his nation
but first the emperor wanted that nation to expand
for decades ethiopia's north had been cut off from
the ocean by the italian colony of eritrea with
italy now defeated selassie approached president
roosevelt in february 1945 with a request the
territory be handed to him after the war at
first uncle sam simply promised to think about it
but as the hot war ended and the cold war began
it became clear that an american-friendly port
on the red sea could be extremely darn useful
in 1949 a joint un allied powers report declared
eritrea was incapable of sustaining itself as an
independent nation three years later it was joined
in a federation with ethiopia selassie's first
major geopolitical win in this new world order
and this was an order the emperor wholeheartedly
embraced despite his disappointments with his
forerunner selassie took ethiopia into the united
nations even sending troops to help during the
korean war at the same time his restored nation
was plugging itself into world markets inviting in
western teachers to educate the populace the rise
of this dynamic new ethiopia culminated in 1955
with a brand new transformative constitution for
the first time an educated lower house would
be formed with law-making powers the judiciary
would be independent the bureaucracy
overhauled and made to serve the people
the franchise was extended to every citizen for
the first time citizens rights were codified
yet for all of its progressive sounding clauses
the 1955 constitution didn't create a democratic
utopia buried amid the text but permeating
every line were sections designed to do nothing
but shore up selassie's power to make sure no one
could so much as question him selassie wanted a
bright shiny new future for ethiopia all right but
only if he was eternally at its very top it would
be this ambition that would turn the final act of
his remarkable life into such an avoidable tragedy
so far in this video we focused on the story
of haile selassie the man the mortal human
who became ethiopia's emperor but there's another
story playing out there in the background taking
place at roughly the same time the story of
how hailey selassie came to be revered as a god
unlike our main story this version of selassie's
tale begins in 1916 when marcus garvey announced
to his followers look to africa for the crowning
of a black king he shall be the redeemer at the
time of course africa was mostly a patchwork of
european colonies a truly independent black king
wasn't something that came along very often
at all so when haile selassie was crowned
at a grand ceremony in 1930 it felt many
among jamaica's poor and disenfranchised
the garvey's prophecy had come true over
the following years the religious teaching
that selassie was incarnate began to spread over
the island taking its name from his old title
and birth name rastafarianism would become one of
the caribbean's great social movements a movement
turbo charged by the italian invasion playing into
rastafarian concepts about babylon in this case
colonial society oppressing black people the
invasion became a rallying cry when zelassi
retook the throne it only confirmed that he was
the prophesized black messiah this elevation in
rasta thought soon got caught up in other cultural
currents swirling through jamaica after denouncing
selassie as a coward garvey changed his mind
and started making ethiopia a focal point of his
back to africa movement this in turn influenced
drastifaris until selassie's kingdom came to be
seen as the promised land of xan it probably
helped that after world war ii selassie had
established a land grant around chasmane village
that black people from the americas could settle
in initially intended for those from the usa
it soon became a focal point of a minor wave
of rastafari immigration finally in 1966 the
emperor made a state visit to jamaica touching
down in kingston on april the 21st so many
rasters swarmed the airport that they took over
the runway turning a working transport hub into
an impromptu religious carnival for rastafarians
selassie's arrival in jamaica was effectively
his second coming to this day april the 21st is
still celebrated as ground nation day the day
jah walked among the ordinary man of kingston
yet even as rastafarians abroad were deifying
him back home selassie's reign was beginning
to lose its shine the trouble was all those young
elites alaska had encouraged into his new schools
were now adults adults with enough education to
question why they were still ruled by an autocrat
it didn't help that selassie responded to a failed
coup by forming a new government composed of the
aristocracy and military elites the impression
was of an emperor no longer taking his nation
forward but rather holding it back especially
when you looked to eritrea in 1962 ethiopia
had dissolved its federation with its northern
neighbor in favor of outright annexation this
had led to an insurgency erupting that tied up the
army and brought in a constant flood of bad news
it was about to get even worse as the 1960s rolled
on other ethnicities within ethiopia's patchwork
of peoples would begin to stage their own revolts
he may have just been recognized as the living
incarnation of god but the mortal man who was
highly selassie would soon have a much bigger
problem making sure that living was exactly what
he continued to do by the close of the 1960s it
was clear ethiopia was in trouble in the cities
socialist inspired students were agitating for
land reform as their leninist doctrine spread
so did the idea that ethnicities should have
the right to secede a right many disaffected
groups eagerly grasped soon uprisings were
springing up alongside the conflict in eritrea
gergium erupted as did sadamo and degray but it
was in wallow that the match would be lit on the
pile of resentful dynamite now underlying society
in 1971 a terrible drought struck ethiopia laying
waste to the countryside that year food stocks had
to be eaten to supplement the terrible harvest
when drought again hit the following year even
the seeds and the grain was consumed all of this
led to an inevitable and horrific outcome in 1973
famine today it's unknown exactly how many died
in the wallow famine although estimates place it
as around 200 000 people but the real problem
was selassie's reaction rather than beg the
international community for help the emperor tried
to hide what was happening even throwing sumptuous
banquets to cover up the food scarcity so when the
news finally broke it made the emperor not just
look callous but actively cruel and that tipped
the scales from we need reform two that all has
to go in june 1974 following six months of strikes
rioting chaos a bunch of military officials and
self-proclaimed socialists formed a committee
known as the durg on september 12th they overthrew
selassie in a coup dragging him from his palace
as crowds jeered and shouted insults initially the
dirk wanted to play selassie's son on the throne
but when crown prince asked for wasps and refused
to go along with them the derg were all like all
right fine i guess we'll just rule by ourselves
then the announcement of a communist state on
december 20th effectively ended the ethiopian
monarchy after 3 000 years in its place came a
military hunter that would take ethiopia into
a series of wars and famine far more terrible
than anything that happened on selassie's watch
but the last emperor wouldn't be around to see
it on august 27 1975 the dirk pursley announced
that selassie had died of natural causes while
that's not impossible for a man of 83 many still
believe he was murdered especially given his final
resting place after the fall of the derg in 1992
selassie's bones were found entombed in concrete
beneath the private toilet of the durg's leader
colonel mengistu it would take until november
2000 for his relatives to finally receive an
official re-burial today as when the emperor
was alive there exist two hailey selassies
one is the selassie of raster thought a black
spiritual leader that a million people worship
and millions more have heard about this selassie
is an icon not just for his role in rastafarianism
but for being a powerful african leader at
a time when most of africa was subjugated
but there's also another selassi one who started
out as a reformer only to wind up being consumed
by his inability to reform as fast as his people
needed this selassie is all too human a remarkable
man but still just a man and one who sadly
ended his reign not beloved but driven from
power whichever selassie you believe in though
there's no doubting his historical significance as
the last emperor of ethiopia selassie guided one
of africa's most important countries through an
era of bloodshed and change that effectively
turned a medieval society into a modern state
he may not have been perfect his improvements may
have been broadly undone by the durg's bloody rule
but he still was a transformative leader one
whose name will echo throughout history you